INTO THE RADICAL SQUAD
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
ADJOINING US WITH REACTION,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KARL ROVE.
WE CAN ADD TO THAT, OF COURSE,
THE COMPARISON TO NAZI GERMANY
BY CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR, HER
VIRULENT ANTI-SEMITISM, AND
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ,
USING THE TERM IN COMPARISON
TO CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN BETWEEN
WEDNESDAY AND THE LOVE OF
MUELLER AND THE NEW GREEN DEAL
THAT HAS GRIPPED THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES ON THE
DEMOCRAT SIDE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, SEAN, I WANT TO
PUT TO BED THE UGLY RUMOR THAT
IS FLOATING AROUND WASHINGTON
THAT THE EFFORT TO ELEVATE OMAR,
TLAIB, PRESSLEY, AND AOC IS A
RESULT OF A SECRET PLOT
CONCOCTED IN THE UNDERGROUND
HEADQUARTERS OF THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT.
THIS IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE AND IS
NOT -- AS HELPFUL AS THEY HAVE
BEEN TO SHOWING WHAT THE NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS A CHANCE TO
TURN INTO, I WANT TO SAY THAT
THIS IS NOT -- I HAVE EXAMINED
IT.
I HAVE LOOKED DEEPLY.
I HAVE READ THE SECRET MINUTES
OF THE SECRET MEETINGS OF THE
REPUBLICAN ILLUMINATI, AND I
FIND NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER THAT
THESE FOUR PEOPLE WERE ELECTED
TO OFFICE WITH THE HELP OF
CONSERVATIVES AND REPUBLICANS
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE DOING THIS ALL ON THEIR
OWN.
THEY ARE HELPING ADVANCE A
CONSERVATIVE AGENDA ALL ON THEIR
OWN.
THEY ARE HELPING ENTHUSE AND
MOTIVATE THE CONSERVATIVES ALL
ON THEIR OWN.
THEY ARE HELPING SET UP A
SITUATION WHERE THE PRESIDENT
COULD BE REELECTED IN 2020.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TAINTED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS BEING AS FAR
LEFT AS THEY ARE.
THEY ARE DOING IT ALL ON THEIR
OWN.
THIS IS THEIR OWN IDEA.
>> Sean: SO YOU HAVE SOME
CALLING THE COUNTRY GARBAGE, AND
THEN YOU HAVE A GUARANTEED
DESTRUCTION OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY, NO OIL, GAS ENGINES,
AND EVERYTHING IS FREE.
THEN YOU HAVE THIS UNPRECEDENTED
ANTI-SEMITISM, ISRAEL HAS
HYPNOTIZED THE WORLD, MAY ALLAH
AWAKEN PEOPLE.
>> IT IS ALL ABOUT THE
BENJAMINS.
>> Sean: ALL ABOUT THE
AND OF COURSE THE COMPARISONS TO
NAZI GERMANY THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE, BOTH ISRAEL AND THE U.S.
DETENTION CENTERS.
SO WHERE DOES -- HOW DOES THIS
IMPACT 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
HOPEFULS?
>> WE ARE PAYING A LOT OF
ATTENTION TO THESE FOUR.
AND IT IS TAINTING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHEN AOC STOOD UP AND SAID GREEN
NEW DEAL, SHE MADE A GREAT
MANY -- CAN YOU IMAGINE THE
STATE OF TEXAS IF THAT WAS A
POTENTIAL REALITY?
WITHIN TEN YEARS, ALL OF THAT
OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT IN WEST
TEXAS IS GOING TO GO AWAY.
THOSE BILLIONS UPON BILLIONS
UPON BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INVESTED IN REFINERIES IS GOING
TO GO.
THE UTILITY RATES WILL GO
THROUGH THE ROOF, EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
RENEWABLES IN THE TEXAS ENERGY
SUPPLY.
TWO GREAT AIRLINES, AMERICAN AND
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES, WILL SEE
THROUGH SOME UNSPECIFIED
GOVERNMENT POWER, PUTTING
PASSENGER PLANES AND THE AIR AND
HAVE PEOPLE TRAVEL FOR A
VACATION OR BUSINESS OR
PLEASURE.
ALL OF THAT WILL GO AWAY.
WHAT THESE PEOPLE ARE DOING TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY
NANCY PELOSI MUST BE PULLING OUT
HER HAIR, WHILE CHUCK SCHUMER IS
JUST GOING NUTS.
THEY ARE DOING DEEP DAMAGE TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU ADVISE TO
REPUBLICANS ON WEDNESDAY?
I HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK MUELLER.
>> I'D SAY TWO THINGS.
LAY THE PREDICATE FOR THE IG AND
THE AG.
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY GOING TO
GET TO THE HEART OF WHETHER
THERE WAS FISA ABUSE AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2016.
REMEMBER MUELLER IS NOT
APPOINTED UNTIL MAY OF 2017.
THE ABUSES TOOK PLACE IN 2016.
LAY THE PREDICATE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, EVERY TIME THE
DEMOCRATS GO AFTER ONE OF THESE
OBSTRUCTION CHARGES, ASK
MUELLER, DO YOU STAND BY YOUR
STATEMENT THAT THIS REPORT DOES
NOT CONCLUDE THAT THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED A CRIME?
THOSE WERE THE WORDS.
THIS DOES NOT CONCLUDE THAT THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME, DO
YOU STILL STAND BY THOSE WORDS?
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, KARL, I
THINK THAT THE HEADLINE WILL BE
"KARL ROVE ADMITS CONSERVATIVE
CONSPIRACY THEORY TO CREATE THE
SQUAD" HAS BEEN EXPOSED ON
"HANNITY."
THE ILLUMINATI AS WELL.
>> THERE WILL BE SOMEBODY ON THE
LEFT WHO THINKS THAT, BUT MAYBE
THEY WON'T.
WHATEVER.
I JUST WANT TO BE ON THE RECORD.
>> Sean: WE WILL PUT IT ON THE
WHITEBOARD.
>> I WANT TO SEE THE EMAILS, I
WANT TO SEE YOUR EMAILS,
IT MAY HAVE STARTED IN YOUR